um  i thought you guys here  my god  oh my god  i'm so tired i just came from the gym  i'm like exhausted  all right guys  i'm literally exhausted  okay  guys what should i do tonight let me  know in the chat i need something to do  okay guys put questions in the chat  actually i should have made can i edit  my  chat name or no because i want to do  like a q a  while i'm waiting  kind of bored  i wish i could  hang you guys somewhere while i drove  because  yeah  perfect plan  go watch spiderman i don't like movies  okay  look at you guys  i know i should do this before  you guys roast me sometimes  look i am who i am  driving while white ooh perfect  switch you guys there  and then you guys can let me know in the  chat  any questions you guys have  i should wait  this is my brother's car  oh gosh  no